(suspenseful music)
- These are all of the
volcanoes in the world.
You've got this big
strip here in Ethiopia,
a big cluster up in Iceland,
and a long strip down the
west coast of the Americas.
But there's one spot
that has more volcanoes
than anywhere else on Earth,
right here in Indonesia.
And it's not even all of Indonesia,
this country of 17,000 islands.
It's really this belt right here.
This is called the Sunda Arc.
And it's where the majority
of volcanic activity
in Indonesia is happening.
It's where the violence, the intensity,
the beauty of all of these
blasts is taking place.
I want to show you some of
the most striking volcanoes
on Earth, and I'm doing this
because I want to try to better understand
why they are so deadly
and why millions of people
live right in the shadow
of these sleeping dragons.
(suspenseful music)
Okay. Let's quickly go
over why volcanoes exist.
Maybe you've heard this
before, but I'm going to try
to explain it in a way that makes sense.
It's important to remember that the ground
under your feet is actually a giant plate
a hundred kilometers thick,
one of many plates floating
around on molten lava.
They're all moving in certain directions
and at different speeds.
There are seven main plates on Earth
and a bunch of smaller ones.
And they're always moving.
When these plates move into
each other, they make mountains.
When they spread apart, they
make underwater volcanoes
that cool and turn into rocks
and we call them islands.
When they slide against each other
they make terrible earthquakes.
And when they run into each other
and one gets forced below the other,
they make volcanoes.
- [Narrator] A whole series
of volcanoes begins to pop up
along the edge of the continent,
parallel to the trench.
- So the real reason why this
one strip of land in Indonesia
has so many volcanoes
is because this plate
is slamming into this plate at a rate
of seven centimeters a year,
which is one of the fastest movements
of plates in the world.
So you're getting a ton of this,
which results in a ton of this.
(exciting music)
If you zoom into one of these volcanoes,
you're going to see a
lot of this dark green
around the volcano where no one lives.
But all of this, each
one of these little dots,
are villages where tons of people live.
And they're right in the
strike zone of this volcano.
Volcanoes kill people
when they suddenly erupt,
but it's not the lava that kills them.
It's the ash.
This huge column of ash
and gases first goes up
and then it eventually falls down.
As it falls it gains momentum
on these steep mountain sides.
And eventually that
will slam into villages
up to three kilometers in
radius from the volcano.
If you were standing in the
way of one of these massive
ash avalanches, you will die.
And then if it rains, it gets really bad,
because the ash and the
rain make these horrifying
mud rivers that cut through the mountain
and flood villages all around the region.
Okay, before we go any further
I want to thank today's
sponsor, which is Morning Brew.
Morning Brew is a free daily newsletter,
Monday through Sunday.
I love Morning Brew because it is
a great way to start your day.
I used to start my mornings
just sort of like rolling over,
opening my phone and wandering
through several apps.
not really knowing what
I should be reading.
Morning Brew is a clear,
concise, and honestly
witty and fun-to-read
newsletter that focuses you
on the relevant news in
everything from tech to business
to what's happening in the world.
One of the things I've been following
is the cryptocurrency world.
And obviously I made a video about NFTs.
They're witty. They're
asking the right questions.
It's just a really nice, solid breakdown
that's fun and very
quick and easy to read.
Again, there's nothing to sell here.
Morning Brew is a free newsletter.
It takes 15 seconds to sign up.
There's a link in my description.
Clicking that link helps
support this channel
but it also allows you to sign up
for this awesome newsletter.
For five minutes a day
you're getting smarter
and more informed about today's news.
Thank you Morning Brew
for sponsoring this video
and let's get back to volcanoes.
Every volcano has its own personality.
And I want to show you some
of the most striking volcanoes
along this strip and in the process,
explain how and why humans live so close
to these sleeping dragons.
(exciting music)
First, let's talk about Kawah Ijen.
This volcano blew up
really bad 3,000 years ago,
and left a one kilometer
wide crater that is now full
of this bright blue, very acidic water.
The most acidic lake on Earth,
because under the surface
there is a huge deposit of sulfuric gas
that is venting out of
this crack in the earth.
All of this sulfur gas
means that when this thing
erupts with lava, it burns that gas
and ignites it in this
mesmerizing blue flame.
All of this gas also means
that there is some money to be made.
The locals have installed
these ceramic pipes
to catch the gases and force
it to condense into a liquid.
It flows down here to where it cools
and turns into a solid which
can be harvested by locals.
My friend Christian is there right now,
covering the realities of this job.
I'm going to let him show you
what this work is actually like.
- Hey, Johnny.
So right now we are inside of
Kawah Ijen, a active volcano.
And this crater is full of life.
You can see all the steam
rising off of the water,
this insane plume of yellow smoke,
and this yellow smoke is
what creates the sulfur.
And with me here are the
bad-ass, hardworking dudes.
No other way to put it.
They're literal superheroes..
- [Man] This here is
Supano. What's up Supano?
- I've had this amazing
opportunity to just pick his brain,
try to understand a little bit better
why is it that these guys are taking on
some of the most
challenging work conditions
on planet Earth.
What is the heaviest weight
that you'll take up the hill?
- 75 kilogram.
- 75 kilograms.
I just tried 40. I could barely manage it.
I mean, you look at these guys,
they're not bodybuilders,
but they're strong minded.
They're incredibly driven
and they've got a good purpose for it.
- How much money? For one kilo only 1,250.
- [Christian] So how much do
you make at the end of the day?
- 300,000.
- If you were to convert
that to you U.S. dollars
that's about 20 to $21 for the
entire day's worth of work.
(exciting music)
- These workers make it into town
where they sell this sulfur to factories,
which mainly use it to bleach
sugar so that it's white.
It's back-breaking, dangerous work.
Christian made a whole
video from this mine
and the realities of this work.
I will link to that in the description.
Next up we have Mount
Merapi or Fire Mountain.
This volcano has killed
more humans than any other.
It erupts all of the time,
like every few years.
Here it is erupting just last year.
This thing is happening over
the course of five minutes.
This time-lapse was recorded
by VolcanoYT and Frekom,
two different YouTube
channels that we'll link to
in the description.
The reason why this volcano is so deadly
is because like I said before,
there are millions of
people living around it.
And not just remotely around it,
like right up against the mountain.
Here's the volcano.
And these are all the
villages right up against it.
Which raises an important question
I had going into this story,
which is why do so many people live here?
Like so many people.
The answer is that this is
an amazing place to live.
(upbeat music)
Indonesia has mild warm weather.
It rains super hard for a few months
and that rain is effectively
stored in these mountains.
And it provides water to these
people throughout the year.
And then there's the fact that
this is perfect fertilizer,
all mashed up and broken down,
ready to make this soil
incredibly fertile.
This is some of the most
fertile land on Earth.
You get three rice harvests
from this soil every year
because the soil is like magic.
So yeah, the people
living here are sort of
in a high risk, high reward situation.
They live on a sleeping dragon
that could wipe them out at any moment.
And yet, as long as it doesn't,
they have some of the best weather
and growing conditions on Earth.
Next up is Krakatau.
What you're looking at here is actually
like a graveyard of what
used to be a big island.
It used to look a lot more like this,
but a hundred years ago, it blew up.
We think this is the
most explosive volcano
in modern history.
10% of the world could hear
the blast, it is so intense.
Tens of thousands were killed in the ash
and the ash exploded so high into the air
that all the way in Europe
the sky was red and hazy.
Which has led some to speculate
that it was this event
that inspired the red hazy
look of this painting,
one of the most famous
paintings in the world
called "The Scream".
(exciting music)
The volcano that grew out of
Krakatau has kept erupting
over the years, breaking
this island down further
and further until the whole
thing just eventually collapsed
and caused a huge tsunami
that killed hundreds.
Just a couple of years
ago, the island went
from looking like this to this.
And today it's one of the fastest growing
volcanoes in the world, and will certainly
be back for more destruction.
Okay, the last one I want to talk about
is this set of volcanoes.
This one is Mount Bromo and
this one is Mount Semeru.
First off, these two
volcanoes are some of the most
stunning volcanoes I've
ever seen in my life,
but they also represent the
deep religious symbolism
that volcanoes have come
to symbolize over time.
This mountain, Mount
Semeru, is named after
the mythical Mount Meru,
which is a sacred five-peaked mountain
in the cosmology of three religions;
Hindu, Jain, and Buddhism.
It is considered to be
the center of the physical
and metaphysical and spiritual universes.
The neighboring volcano
is also deeply symbolic.
It's called Bromo, which
in Javanese is the name
for Rama or the Hindu god of creation.
Every year, Hindus hike up this mountain
and make an offering of
vegetables and plants and animals
to the gods embodied in this volcano.
(gentle music)
There are so many more
volcanoes in Indonesia.
And my goal is to go to
Indonesia with my camera
and actually photograph them for myself.
A lot of the footage from this
video came from Christian,
who gave me a lot of his footage.
He lives in Indonesia
and from other places.
I didn't go there, but I really want to.
I'm now deeply fascinated with volcanoes
because I've been deeply
diving into plate tectonics.
So I hope you understand more
about why volcanoes exist,
why so many exists in Indonesia,
and how the people cope living next to
these ticking time bombs.
What's so intriguing to me is
that the volcano is a giver.
It gives abundance and
fertility most of the time.
But sometimes it chooses to take away.
Okay. That's it.